you
you
were talking one of them said who can
see
nothingness as his own head life as his
own spine
and death as his own ass who knows the
single body
formed by life and death existence and
non-existence
i will be his friend the four looked at
one another and laughed feeling complete
concorde and became friends
suddenly zu took ill zg went to see him
and zu said how great is the creator of
things
making me all tangled up like this for
his chin was tucked into his navel
his shoulders towered over the crown of
his head
his ponytail pointed towards the sky his
five internal organs
at the top of them his thigh bones
taking the place of his ribs
and his yin and yang energies in chaos
but his mind
was relaxed and unbothered he hobbled
over to the well to get a look at his
reflection
wow he said the creator of things has
really gone and tangled me up
cg said do you dislike it zu said
not at all what is there to dislike
perhaps he will transform my left arm
into a rooster
thereby i'll be announcing the dawn
perhaps he will transform my right arm
into a crossbow pellet
thereby i'll be seeking out an owl to
roast perhaps he will transform my ass
into wheels and my spirit into a horse
thereby i'll be riding along will i ever
need another vehicle
anyway getting it is a matter of the
time coming
and losing it is just something else to
follow along with
content in the time and finding one's
place in the process of following along
joy and sorrows are unable to seep in
this is what the ancients called the
dangle and release
we cannot release ourselves being beings
we are always tied up by something
but it has long been the case that mere
beings cannot overpower
heaven what is there for me to dislike
about
it suddenly zelay fell ill
gasping and wheezing on the verge of
kneeling over he was surrounded by his
weeping family
ziller coming to visit him said to them
ah away with you
do not disturb his transformation
leaning across that windowsill he said
to the invalid
how great is the process of creation
transformation
what will it make you become where will
it send you will it make you into a
mouse's liver
or perhaps an insect's arm zelai said
a child obeys his parents wherever they
may send him
north south east or west now yin and
yang are much more to a man
than his parents if they send me to my
death and i disobey them that would make
me a traitor
what fault would it be of theirs the
great clump burdens me with a physical
form labors me with life eases me with
old age and rests me
with death hence it is precisely because
i regard my life
as good that i regard my death as good
now suppose a great master smith were
casting metal
if the metal jumped up and said i insist
on being nothing but an excalibur
the smith would surely consider it to be
an inauspicious chunk of metal
now if i having happened to stumble into
a human form
should insist only a human only a human
creation transformation would certainly
consider me an inauspicious chunk of
person
so now i look upon all heaven and earth
as a great
furnace and creation transformation as a
great blacksmith
where could i go that would not be all
right
all at once i fall asleep with a start
i awaken
you